how do you stop a lightsaber mid-swing
why you use the force of course but two
of the Star Wars characters were pulled
off this incredible ability after
returning to the Star Wars Spotlight in
the last episode of Ahsoka Ezra Bridger
is back in action for the show's latest
installment in dreams and Madness Ezra
teams up with Sabine Wren to take on the
Marauders of paridia grand Amaral
thrawn's night Troopers and shinharti
naturally between her knowledge of the
force and lightsaber abilities shimposes
by far the biggest threat but both Ezra
and Sabine are prepared for her attack
just like you but lots your sense of
humor
lightsaber oh yeah
great boldly Ezra wields nothing but the
force in this fight with Shin even using
it to hold back one of her lightsaber
swings it's an awesome moment in the
midst of a frantic fight and improves
just how strong Ezra has become as a
force user for reference in the Disney
plus series Obi-Wan Kenobi The Fearsome
and immensely powerful Darth Vader uses
a similar technique during his brief
clash with Riva Vader uses a force to
prevent several of us drugs from landing
and even prevents a specialized
double-bladed lightsaber from spinning
these aren't the only Force users who
have nailed this impressive ability
however Ezra and Vader's move have also
been depicted on the big screen via the
Star Wars sequel Trilogy though the
return of fun favorites such as Luke
Skywalker Han Solo and Princess Leia
were a big selling point of the sequel
Trilogy these movies also boast a number
of franchise newcomers among these
heroes and villains are Ray Skywalker
and kylo ren who clashed throughout the
force awakens The Last Jedi and the rise
of Skywalker and as their doll in the
third film that is totally relevant here
in the rise of Skywalker Rey and kylo
cross Sabers in the wreckage of the
second death star as gigantic waves
crash around them and their situation
becomes increasingly perilous they both
managed to employ the same technique as
Ezra Bridger and Darth Vader early on in
the fight Ray briefly stops kylo Ren's
red lightsaber by using the force
prompting him to do the same when she
attacks moments later seeing as kylo is
her grandson of Vader and Rey is a
granddaughter of Emperor Palpatine
there's perhaps no surprise that they've
both mastered this immensely useful
Force ability and he has a little known
fact for you at one point another famous
Jedi was supposed to use this power long
before fans saw Ezra Bridger Darth Vader
kylo Ren or Rey Skywalker stop
lightsaber Swings with the force Luca's
film was hard at work wrapping up the
Skywalker Saga the rise of Skywalker was
a film that ended it all though the
version of episode 9 fans saw in
theaters in 2019 was vastly different
from the one envisioned by the film's
original director Colin travaro the
script for travaro's take on the story
known as doll of the Fates has been
online for some time some interesting
features include Finn leading a
full-blown Stormtrooper Uprising kylo
pursuing even more Dark Side power and
the now Infamous stage direction that
claims hooks lost the Star Wars at one
point the script also includes a pretty
wild move pulled off by the Force ghost
of Luke Skywalker as The Last Jedi end
of Luke passing into the force it's no
surprise that he's present in the script
for Duel of the Fates Luke pops up here
and there throughout the story taunting
kylo from beyond the grave and it all
culminates in him making his presence
truly felt during kylo's Final Duel with
Rey during this fight Luke grabs hold of
his nephew's lightsaber by The Flaming
crackling blade look deep enough on the
internet and you'll even find the
concept art drawn up for this moment
it's an undeniably cool visual even if
it is a move that living Star Wars
characters would be wise not to
replicate clearly this Force block
ability is becoming more and more
commonplace in the franchise we'll just
have to wait and see if any more
characters use it as a Star Wars
universe us continues to expand
foreign